good morning John it's Friday a few
years ago I think I kind of decided that
I was going to try to get big on Tick
Tock I missed being a part of the rising
of a new platform like that was a really
rewarding experience when it happened
with YouTube and it's it's sort of
lovely it's very creative it's very
interesting and it felt that way when I
joined Tick Tock and and you know I was
right there was so much interesting
stuff happening on the platform and I've
learned a huge amount and I now have
seven million followers on Tick Tock
which is more than I have anywhere else
and so one has to ask could I do it
again is there another social media
platform that I could grow a large
audience on Like It's tricky because
it's not really about the age of the
platform that's a mistake it's about how
it's being utilized and whether it's
being underutilized by the people
currently there it's about whether it
would be creatively fulfilling for me
and whether what I bring would be
valuable to it anyway a couple of weeks
ago I decided I was going to get to a
million followers on LinkedIn no I did
not realize when I said this that
getting to a million followers on
LinkedIn would make you one of the
hundred top business influencers in the
world so I have revised my goals since
then instead my goal now is just to like
uh be making better content than most of
the other people on the site which John
I have to say does not seem like it
would be hard now my biggest problem is
that the way that most people use
LinkedIn is like pretty serious and
while I am a serious guy in some of the
things that I do in ways that I act
those are not easily visible on the
platforms that I use I am publicly goofy
which I like that's a thing I like about
me and about the way that I use the
internet and so as with most things uh
you turn to your toolkit to your
strengths and I got a tool kit I've been
working on it for a long time so let's
see what I made in my first couple of
weeks as a linked influencer
I started out with this one about
elephant balls that's right the largest
land animal on Earth but no balls that
doesn't mean they don't have big
testicles they do an individual
Fantastical could easily weigh more than
your head but very unusually for land
mammals elephants have internal
testicles the business lesson here is
you don't have to be showy to make a
huge impact many of the people I know
who deliver the most value never shove
it in other people's faces I guess I've
been on the internet for as long as
that's been a job that people can have
and one thing I know for sure is
platforms stop being fun the moment that
popularity on that platform delivers a
significant amount of societal status
this explains why LinkedIn has never
been fun this one says taxes are a
percentage of income but I think other
things should be a percentage of income
like traffic fines and also maybe there
should be an income-based surcharge for
cheap things that save time like fast
food if my time's worth so much money
then isn't charging me fifty dollars for
a McDouble the free market thing to do
and then I put this minion made of glass
underneath it I just thought maybe
they'd like that Venus fly traps have to
put their flowers really far away from
their traps so they don't accidentally
kill their pollinators the business
lesson here is your product team should
be super separate from your sales team I
don't actually know what that means but
it sounds like it's smart and it is my
top LinkedIn post now this one's from
just yesterday 25 of the meteorites that
fall on Earth are the result of a
collision between two large objects in
the asteroid about half a billion years
ago the number of these rocks hitting
Earth as a rolling average has been
decreasing every year for 500 million
years and it's still a quarter of the
rocks that hit us the business lesson
here is that you should probably accept
that the fact that you were bullied in
middle school is still a pretty big part
of your personality even though it
matters a little less every year I think
this is my most liked post that is just
says my Twitter followers are calling me
out because Lee said Hank to himself
this is great I'm gonna get a good grade
in LinkedIn something that is both
normal to want and possible to achieve
look that's obviously where I'm at and
it's not something I dislike about
myself so I'm just gonna lean on it now
John as you know it took me a while to
get traction on Tick Tock but once that
happened you hopped on the platform and
now we're like sharing the space a
little bit which is lovely and
everything Brothers being Brothers but I
just want you to know that LinkedIn is
mine John I'll see you on Tuesday